präsident liebe kolleginnen und kollegen
ich danke ihnen und dem ältestenrat und
den fraktionen für das entgegenkommen
dass wir in dieser aus holz woche eine
etwas ungewöhnliche form der debatten
führung miteinander verabreden konnten
das hat vieles erleichtert und ich bin
dankbar dafür liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen die
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen wir leben
in zeiten
der unsicherheit in zeiten von umbrüchen
dieser haushaltsentwurf der
bundesregierung gibt in diesen zeiten
orientierung und setzt prioritäten
erstens rekord investitionen in unsere
zukunft und in die sicherheit dieses
landes und seiner verbündeten zweitens
gezielte entlastungen die abwendung von
sozialen härten
drittens die rückkehr zur schuldenregel
des grundgesetzes aus diesem haushalt
spricht
entscheidungskraft und
konsequenz die zeitenwende konnten wir
nicht beeinflussen sie ist über uns
gekommen durch den schrecklichen
angriffs russlands auf die ukraine aber
wir sind nicht schicksalhaft dieser
zeitenwende unterworfen sondern wir sind
gestalterinnen und gestalter
unseres schicksals um dieser haushalt
gibt dafür eine richtung vor
für den umgang mit krisen gibt es ja 33
formen die erste form des umgangs mit
einer krise ist die ängste der menschen
zu teilen
und das führt schnell zu entscheidungen
nur mit einem geringen zeitlichen
horizont
dann gibt es die möglichkeit die ängste
der menschen verstärken zu wollen um
daraus politisches kapital schlagen zu
wollen
darauf zu hoffen dass sich die ängste
der menschen in wahrheit bestätigen um
den eigenen politischen erfolg darauf zu
gründen und es gibt den weg den wir als
koalition eingehen die ängste der
menschen kennen aber alles zu
unternehmen die ängste der menschen
durch entschlossenes politisches handeln
zu reduzieren das ist unser weg
wir wollen das land nicht spalten
sondern wir wollen es aus dieser krise
heraus in seine zukunft führen und
deshalb ist dieser etat nicht alleine
ein krisen etat sondern einen etat der
auch mutige schwerpunkte für die zukunft
setzt ich denke an die investitionen die
wir möglich machen in erneuerbare
energien
das
umfängliche
finanzierungsvolumen für saubere
technologie unsere maßnahmen zur
stärkung zur ertüchtigung unserer
infrastruktur der koalitionsausschuss
vom wochenende hat hier noch einen
zusätzlichen schwerpunkt gesetzt im
bereich der verkehr und insbesondere der
schieneninfrastruktur 50 milliarden euro
an investitionen alleine im jahr
2023 alleine aus dem bundeshaushalt die
mittel aus den programmen des klima und
transformations- fonds kommen dort noch
dazu verehrte anwesende liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen die
transformation unseres landes setzen wir
nicht trotz der zeitenwende fort
transformation unseres landes denen der
verstärkt an wegen dieser krise und der
prioritäten die sie von uns verlangt
aber das kostet geld
all das kostet geld wir führen ja auch
eine
haushaltsberatung und dennoch erlaube
ich mir an dieser stelle zu sagen dass
das geld aus dem staatshaushalt eben
nicht allein entscheidend ist um zukunft
zu gewinnen sondern möglicherweise ist
das was aus dem privaten sektor auch an
privatem kapital mobilisiert werden kann
entscheidend dafür dass die
transformation gelingt dafür der kollege
justizminister marco buschmann und ich
zum beispiel eckpunkte für ein
zukunftsinvestitionsgesetz vorgelegt und
die bundesregierung hat sich ehrgeizige
pläne gesetzt um auch schon in diesem
herbst die planungs und
genehmigungsverfahren
so zu beschleunigen dass erneuerbare
energie in ihren kapazitäten gesteigert
wird die infrastruktur modernisiert wird
und auch private wirtschaftliche
vorhaben realisiert werden können unser
land kann vieles unser land kann mehr
wir müssen dafür sorgen dass das was in
unserem land steckt in dieser speziellen
krise auch endlich zur entfaltung kommen
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen die sind
ökonomische in einer außerordentlich
herausfordernden lage das wurde durch
die zinsentscheidung der europäischen
zentralbank heute ja auch noch einmal
deutlich an starker zinsschritt der
verdeutlicht dass alle sich der
herausforderung stellen müssen die
inflation zu bekämpfen das an der stelle
einmal zu sagen würde auch niemand jetzt
von einem liberalen finanzminister was
anderes erwarten wenn ich sage dass ihr
wirtschaftlicher prosperität und
wachstum wollen aber in dieser
speziellen wirtschaftlichen situation
liegt die priorität auf der bekämpfung
der inflation
denn inflation ist das
verarmungsprogramm für die familien in
der mitte der gesellschaft inflation
führte dazu dass unternehmerische
risiken gescheut und investitionen
unterlassen werden deshalb ist die erste
priorität die inflation zu bekämpfen
denn sie würde sonst unser
wirtschaftliches fundament unterspülen
dabei
aber wirklich klar machen dass hier
nichts nicht jede jede
herausforderung mit staatlichen mitteln
abfedern können wir können soziale
härten verhindern wirtschaftliche
struktur brüche abwenden aber wir müssen
realistisch sein und wir dürfen keine
falschen hoffnungen wecken wir können
nicht alles abwenden was an
herausforderungen auf unser land zu
kommen wir dürfen auch diesen falschen
eindruck nicht erwecken weil wir den
menschen natürlich die realistische
möglichkeit geben müssen auch der
wirtschaft sich vorzubereiten aber eine
zusage kam diese bundesregierung eben
das politische versprechen aufgrund von
finanziellen sorgen wird in diesem land
in diesem winter niemand frieren und
niemand hunger
am wochenende ein entlastungspaket 3 mit
einer größenordnung von schätzungsweise
65 milliarden euro
politische verabredet es sind nicht nur
maßnahmen die auf den bundeshaushalt
2023 gerichtet sind sondern auch solche
die aus anderen vorhaben ich kann mir
gleich kurz darauf zu sprechen sich
speisen und natürlich auch in diesem
jahr wollen wir noch etwas möglich
machen ich spreche über das wohngeld und
das bürgergeld ab dem 11 12 01 23 aber
in diesem jahr ist es möglich geworden
aufgrund der sorgsamen haushaltsführung
und der entwicklung der öffentlichen
einnahmen ist es möglich geworden in
diesem jahr noch den rentnerinnen und
rentnern für diesen winter eine
einmalzahlung von 300 euro zukommen zu
lassen ein klares zeichen dafür dass die
koalition niemanden in unserem land
vergisst
haben uns
wir haben uns vorgenommen die kalte
progression im nächsten jahr zu
verhindern dass muss ich an der stelle
einmal einmal sagen ist eine frage der
gerechtigkeit
für mich ist die abwendung der kalten
progression nicht im engeren sinne eine
entlastungsmaßnahmen sondern die abwehr
zusätzlicher belastung nehmen wir die
bezieher eines mittleren einkommens von
43000 euro das ist das mittlere
einkommen in deutschland im nächsten
jahr sind die 43.000 euro vielleicht
noch 39.000 euro kaufkraft wert und dann
sollen diese menschen besteuert werden
als wären es 43.000 euro noch das wäre
eine zusätzliche belastung und das würde
menschen in dieser schwierigen zeit ihre
gasrechnung selber zahlen das leben noch
schwerer machen und deshalb ist es
richtig dass die ampel koalition sich
darauf verständigt hat die kalte
progression im nächsten jahr zu
beseitigen
ich habe mich jetzt wir haben jetzt
übrigens
bezeichnet dass die unionsfraktion nicht
applaudiert vielleicht ist das auch kein
zufall denn ich habe heute auf twitter
gelesen dass das mitglied der cdu csu
bundestagsfraktion tillmann kuban in
seiner funktion als bundesvorsitzender
der jungen union gestern auf einer
podiumsdiskussion gesagt haben soll
jetzt sei der falsche zeitpunkt die
kalte progression zu bekämpfen da möchte
ich fragen wann ist denn dann der
richtige zeitpunkt die kalte progression
zu bekämpfen
ich halte
entschuldigen entschuldigen sie bitte
wenn ich sehe kurz darüber unterrichten
darf dass dieser deutsche bundestag
rückwirkung zum ersten ersten dieses
jahres den grundfreibetrag und den
arbeitnehmerpauschbetrag erhöht hat also
fährt in diesem jahr gab es gab es
bereits maßnahmen
da ist dazu bereits maßnahmen nur hätte
man pro bahn kann kann seine äußerung
zeit noch gerade rücken ich hab es nicht
im original sondern nur auf twitter die
die die kolportage aber es hat mir eins
gezeigt wenn ich so ehrlich sein darf
auch die die produktive spannung
innerhalb der ampel koalition in dieser
frage hat mir eins gezeigt wir müssen
uns die frage stellen wie wir mit der
kalten progression eigentlich dauerhaft
umgehen wenn ich mit meinen kollegen
finanzministerien und finanzminister in
europa spreche und wir vergleichen
unsere entlastungsmaßnahmen dann
sagen die immer ja wir machen aber
nichts bei der lohn und einkommenssteuer
habe ich dann gesagt ja sich in
deutschland schlage vor dass wir die
kalte progression beseitigen wir machen
schon was bei der steuer und dann sagen
ach so die das machen wir automatisch
das zählt bei uns gar nicht zur
entlastung oder verhinderung von
belastung während der inflation und nach
der diskussion die wir geführt haben den
äußerungen ic man kuban zugeschrieben
worden sind vielleicht führen wir einmal
die debatte darüber zukünftig den
inflationsausgleich im
einkommensteuerrecht automatisch
vollziehen zu lassen
die kolleginnen und kollegen und es wird
auch wirtschaftshilfen geben der
bundeswirtschaftsminister hat heute dazu
ja auch bereits anregungen gegeben die
wir jetzt gegenwärtig noch
konkretisieren aber es werden präzise
maßnahmen seien keine die vergleichbar
sind mit der korona pandemie nicht
vergleichbar sein können wenn wir haben
ein angebots und kann nachfrage problem
und wir wollen uns natürlich auch den
fragen der ursachen von steigenden
preisen zu wenden deshalb die ampel
koalition ja auch beschlossen hatte dass
es eine strompreis bremse in der
energiewirtschaft geben wird wie ich
glaube ein überlegenes instrument denn
in italien hat die dortige sogenannte
über gewinn steuer nicht zu
staatseinnahmen geführt sondern zu
klagen gegen den italienischen staat und
wir brauchen hilfe in der krise und
brauchen keine neuen rechtsstreite mit
ihren unsicherheiten
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen
trotzdem halten wir die schuldenbremse
des grundgesetzes im kommenden jahr ein
der koalitionsausschuss hat das auch
noch einmal am wochenende bestätigt dass
sie an diesem ziel festhalten eine große
herausforderung auch für diese
haushaltsberatungen die entsprechenden
schwerpunktsetzungen vorzunehmen unter
den wirtschaftlichen rahmenbedingungen
indem wir sind aber liebe kolleginnen
und kollegen das ist nicht nur eine
frage oder ist mir wichtig zu sagen eine
frage der verfassung aus
verfassungsgründen ist es ohnehin zwingt
es ist vor allen dingen auch ein gebot
der ökonomischen klugheit ich werde
morgen bedauerlicherweise wieder eine
terminkollision mit den
haushaltsberatungen
ich werde morgen in prag jahr beim
ecofin und bei der euro-gruppe sein
müssen wir wählen auch voraussichtlich
der managing direktor des europäischen
stabilitätsmechanismus also insofern
leider eine unabweisbare verpflichtung
aber ich erwarte dass wir dort morgen
auch im kreis der internationalen
europäischen institutionen und der
mitgliedsländer der eu und der
währungsunion bekräftigen werden dass
wir zur fiskalischen neutralität
zurückkehren müssen das wäre also nicht
die nachfrage und die konjunktur während
der inflation stärken das wird die
gemeinsame fiskalische grundausrichtung
science wird bestätigt werden und darin
liegt eine höhere weisheit
inflation bekämpft man nicht mit immer
neuen staatsschulden sondern nur dadurch
dass man zurück zur seriosität und
solidität findet
in dem zusammenhang da habe ich übrigens
an einer stelle auch sagen dass mir die
äußerungen aus den reihen der unions
fraktion gelegentlich in diesen tagen
etwas rätselhaft vorkommen wir haben
auch sehr genau die beschlüsse der
zugspitze angesehen und das was sie hier
vorgetragen haben ob das auch verglichen
mit dem passiv anlässlich der
haushaltsberatungen
2022 dargelegt haben und man muss leider
wenn ich das so höflich wie zu sagen
darf den eindruck gewinnen dass die die
gipfelhöhe ihre rechenkünste
beeinflusst hat
ebenfalls
kritisieren sie dass ich in diesem jahr
dem bundestag vorschlagen 40 milliarden
euro aus der rücklage zu entnehmen das
kritisieren sie damit wir uns nicht
missverstehen ich halte diese
rücklagenbildung auch für falsch aber
ich hab sie nicht gemacht die
rücklagenbildung habe ich von einer
vorgänger cdu csu geführten
vorgängerregierung übernommen
cdu-geführte vorgängerregierung hat aus
der asyl rücklage 2020 eine allgemeine
rücklage gemacht und angekündigt sie
auflösen zu wollen als anpassung starts
zurück zur schuldenbremse das war ihre
politik jetzt werfen sie mir vor dass
ich diese rücklage aufgeben das finde
ich beachtlich aber noch interessanter
ist dass sie selbst für den haushalt
2022 doch bereits beantragt haben die
kompletten 48 milliarden euro
rücklagen aufzulösen da muss man sie
fragen hätten sie verantwortung was
würden sie dann im haushalt 2023 machen
mit gebildete rücklage und ungefähr 50
milliarden euro mehr forderungen ich
kann nur sagen die union war einmal die
partei die die schwarze null angestrebt
hat bei den haushaltsberatungen der
jüngsten vergangenheit muss ich leider
konstatieren schwarzes loch sind die
konsequenzen dessen was sie
vorgeschlagen habe sondern
16 winter war dass der
bundesfinanzminister hatte hier noch mal
die gelegenheit zu sein im
haushaltsentwurf zu sprechen 2023
insgesamt ein volumen von
445 2 milliarden euro angedockt weit
seine rede an den einzelplan 08 weist
der für finanzen das ist eigentlich
einer der kleineren etats in
anführungszeichen in dieser haushalt
systematik intervention jetzt gibt es
war ja noch kurzinformationen zimmern
kuban der angesprochen war
es ist ja erstaunlich dass sie sich
neuerdings auf twitter informieren es
zeigt mal wieder die qualität der
bundesregierung dann auch bei der frage
wie man sich hier in diesem land
eigentlich auf was verlassen kann was
die informationsquellen ausmacht ich
möchte
[Musik]
wusste allerdings gar nicht dass sie
gestern auch anwesend sonst gewesen
wären davon zu berichten was bei der
veranstaltung diskutiert worden ist
möchte allerdings unseren kritikpunkt
klarstellen nämlich dass sie auf der
einen seite für die transfer
hilfeempfänger für die leute die
wohngeld beziehen eine entlastung
vornehmen dass die dann für eine große
masse von menschen die kleine einkommen
haben nur einen sehr kleinen beitrag nur
einen sehr kleinen beitrag zur verfügung
stellen zur entlastung und dann für
diejenigen die wieder mehr geld
verdienen die kalte progression
abmildern wir sind dafür dass sie
diejenigen entlasten das ist richtig
aber ich möchte ihnen auch sagen die
kleinen und mittleren einkommen in
deutschland hätten mehr verdient als das
was sie als bundesregierung leisten vier
herzlich danke
herr minister sie können antworten
[Applaus]
pflege lieber kollege kuban ich hatte ja
eben gesagt tatsächlich habe ich nur
eine kolportage gesehen aber jetzt ist
nicht ganz klar geworden ob ihre meinung
ist jetzt ist der richtige zeitpunkt
nicht sagen jetzt ja ein anderes
argument vorgetragen und nicht gesagt
was sie tatsächlich gestern abend gesagt
haben aber glaubt das soll sie nicht
zwischen uns stehen denn ich denke in
dem punkt dass die kalte progression im
nächsten jahr abgewendet werden muss
dahinter können wir uns versammeln es
wird sicher auch daran ablesen lassen ob
die cdu csu geführten länder im
bundesrat diesen vorhaben zustimmen und
was sie darüber hinaus gesagt haben zur
entlastungswirkung in der breite die
bundesregierung hat vielfältige
unterschiedliche maßnahmen von denen
alle fallgruppen profitieren die
menschen ihren lebensunterhalt nicht
bestreiten können brauchen natürlich die
solidarität ich habe gehört dass der
bayerische ministerpräsident dazu
kritische anmerkungen gemacht hat für
uns ist das aber entscheidend dass
niemand im winter frieren oder hungern
muss deshalb muss es eine anpassung dort
geben und die breite mitte der
gesellschaft profitiert in vielfältiger
hinsicht insbesondere dort wo kinder
sind und menschen erwerbstätig sind gibt
es spürbare entlastungen und genau das
ist auch die absicht der bundesregierung
wir wollen die menschen in der breite
entlasten insbesondere da wo die bedarfe
besonders groß sind
[Musik]
herr minister dass ich sie bitten stehen
zu bleiben haben eine zweite
kurzintervention vom abgeordneten kai
gottschalk und haben sie auch wieder die
möglichkeit darauf zu antworten
vielen dank frau präsidentin vielen dank
herr minister sie schauten ich gehe
davon aus sie haben sich verguckt so zu
uns rüber als sie meinten es gibt
parteien die würden mit bestimmten
themen profit aus der krise schlagen
wollen ich mache sie darauf aufmerksam
jahr vergeht ihnen vielleicht gleich das
lachen sie haben hoffentlich nicht die
erinnerungslücken des kanzlers in ihrem
wahlprogramm steht und meine fraktion
hat es des öfteren jetzt gefordert
endlich den tarif auf rädern und
tatsächlich die kalte progression
anzugehen wir haben bereits und da sind
wir hier verlacht worden im frühjahr
gefordert jetzt einzuschreiten und haben
die bundes die europäische zentralbank
klar kritisiert für diesen kurs den sie
eingeschlagen hat das macht übrigens
auch die gesamte fachpresse ich hoffe da
haben sie sich verguckt das zweite was
absolut sie haben es eben angeführt
daneben es ist die expertenanhörung sie
nämlich dann zur entlastung des
grundfreibetrags und zur erhöhung
vielleicht sein vergessen haben da wurde
nicht von allen experten gesagt diese
erhöhung die sie jetzt beschließen ist
bereits jetzt unzureichend das versuchen
sie jetzt vielleicht nach zogen aber es
ist immer noch nicht unzureichend sie
können sich vielleicht auch noch
erinnern als ich gesagt habe
siebeneinhalb prozent inflation bedeuten
innerhalb von neun jahren halbiert sich
ihr vermögen habe ich 100 euro schein
entsprechend zerrissen also ich möchte
sie einfach bitten in zukunft wenn
menschen und eine fraktion mit fakten
und wir warnen seit neun jahren davor
dass dieser kurs der ezb dieser kurs den
wir geldpolitisch währungspolitisch hier
in europa eingeschlagen zudem führt was
wir jetzt beobachten einer
galoppierenden inflation und deswegen
ist man nicht ein populist deswegen ist
man kein angst mache ich weiß dass
realisten und menschen die die wahrheit
sagen immer an kalten wind in
deutschland ins gesicht bekommen aber
das möchte ich auch noch mal klarstellen
und ich bitte sie zur kenntnis zu nehmen
und auch damals auf zu antworten ob sie
diese expertenkommission vergessen haben
die ihn klar ins stammbuch geschrieben
hat der grundfreibetrag in dieser höhe
ist ein witz ich könnte jetzt noch auf
die entfernungspauschale
27 die versicherten haben und wenn sie
dann auch sagen 300 euro einmalig auch
versteuert bei mindestens 300 euro
monatlich
angehoben alles klar ist in ordnung also
bis morgen dann freue ich mich drauf
herr minister sie dürfen antworten
daher kollege die europäische
zentralbank steht ja als unabhängige
institution in der tradition der
bundesbank und deshalb deshalb werde
werden sie nicht erwarten dass die
bundesregierung öffentlich ratschläge an
die europäische zentralbank erteilt
inflation ist allerdings nicht nur ein
allein europäisches problem wie sie
gewiss auch wahrgenommen erhaben ich
jedenfalls begrüße dass die
notenbank jetzt sehr entschlossen gegen
die inflation vorgehen durch den
heutigen zinsschritt wir werden das
unsere tun als bundesregierung in den
europäischen gremien auf fiskalische
neutralität zu achten und sehen uns
selbst ja auch in der pflicht
zurückzukehren zum verfassungsgebot der
schuldenbremse hinsichtlich der
entwicklung der kalten progression muss
ich sie darauf aufmerksam machen dass
das verfahren anders ist als sie
dargestellt haben die kalte progression
wird regelmäßig seit etwa einem
jahrzehnt beseitigt zwei jahre im voraus
das heißt die tarife des jahres 22 und
21 wurden
2020 festgelegt auf der basis von
existenzminimum und progression bericht
die bundesregierung hat sich aber
aufgrund der besonderen inflationären
entwicklung dieses jahres dazu
entschlossen zur jahresmitte auf der
basis der frühjahrsprognose
rückwirkend zum ersten ersten eine
außerordentliche inflationsanpassung bei
grundfreibetrag und durch die erhöhung
des arbeitnehmerpauschbetrags
vorzunehmen
jetzt geht es um die ordentliche
anpassung der kalten des tarifverlaufs
zur vermeidung der kalten progression im
regulären verfahren wie alle zwei jahre
da haben wir ein träger gesetz in
vorbereitung des inflationsausgleichs
gesetz mit ebenfalls den entwicklungen
tarif von auf grundfreibetrag auf der
basis der gegenwärtig gültigen prognose
der bundesregierung
sie und ich wir beide wissen dass diese
zahlen nur vorläufigen charakter haben
ich darf sie an ihre redezeit und
deshalb komme ich zum schlusspunkt das
in diesem herbst mit produktions und
existenzminimums bericht dass träger
gesetz inflationsausgleichs gesetz
aktualisiert wird an die zahlen geht
angeboten sind die
[Musik]
ampel koalition in ihrem dritten
entlastungspaket
rede gehen möchte ich gern noch das
protokoll von lesen nämlich das
protokoll für den letzte namentliche
abstimmung über den gesetzentwurf der
fraktion es begeben sollen sich die
grüne und fdp entwurf eines gesetzes zur
stärkung des schutzes der bevölkerung
insbesondere wohl nach personengruppen
pro kubik 19 auf den drucksachen 20 25
73 20 33 12 und 20 33 28 abgegebene
stimmkarten waren 702 mit ja haben
gestimmt
386 mit nein haben gestimmt
313 enthaltungen 3 der gesetzentwurf ist
damit angenommen und wir das war
sozusagen der nachtrag zum neuen
infektionsschutzgesetz darüber wurde
namentlich abgestimmt also der bundestag
hat dem zugestimmt am 16 september
müsste dann noch der bundesrat zustimmen
dann sollen die neuen core ohne regeln
für herbst und winter
erster oktober in kraft treten christian
haase jetzt für die unions fraktion des
bundesrechnungshofes zur lage der
bundesfinanzen für die haushaltsberatung
2023 gelesen selten hat es so eine
fundamentale aber auch berechtigte
kritik am bundeshaushalt vom
bundesrechnungshof gegeben fehlende
transparenz nur scheinbare einsparungen
zum beispiel beim personal und
bedenkliche schieflage zu lasten des
bundes abschließend und das ist
eigentlich die essenz die wir für unsere
beratung auf jeden fall mitnehmen
wollten ein flammender appell des
bundesrechnungshofes sich jetzt nicht
noch in neue schulden zu fliegen das hat
der bundesrechnungshof in einem weiteren
bericht zur tragfähigkeit der
staatsfinanzen gemacht und deshalb
glaube ich ist das sehr wichtig der
bundesrechnungshof kommt dann
abschließend zu dem ergebnis dass man
jetzt klar wenn auch schmerzhafte
entscheidungen braucht um wieder auf
einen verantwortungs basisniveau im
bundeshaushalt zukommen besser hätte ich
selbst nicht sagen können und sehr
bundesfinanzminister lindner können wir
fast leidtun an dieser stelle sie müssen
immer wieder gute miene zum bösen spiel
der ampel machen geplatzte flüssigkeit
stiehlt die erste energie pauschale wo
man rentner und studenten vergisst der
weiterbetrieb der kkw es wird verzögert
und eine völlig missratene gasanlage ein
chaos sagt in dieser regierung das
nächste und die lösung ist oftmals die
gießkanne mit der dann geld ausgebaut
und wird über das ganze land jetzt haben
jetzt haben wir ein neues
entlastungspaket
da werden zwar hier und da alte fehler
korrigiert ich habe darauf hingewiesen
man nimmt einige unserer vorschläge aus
mono oft auch wenn sie das eben
kritisiert haben ein teil davon haben
sie offensichtlich dann am nächsten tag
aufgenommen und abgeschrieben leider
bleibt die finanzierung für mich etwas
unklar 36 milliarden hören wir heute
zehn milliarden werden noch vollkommen
ungedeckt für den bundeshaushalt und
natürlich auch ein teil den dann die
länder übernehmen wollten und sie haben
eben kritisiert dass wir in der
vergangenheit auch zur finanzierung von
entlastungs paketen die rücklage
einsetzen wollten das haben wir
tatsächlich
vorgeschlagen der beratung für den
bundeshaushalt 2020 um die kalte
progression schon zu diesem zeitpunkt
zurückzuführen um den menschen das geld
wieder zu geben was seinerzeit aufgrund
der hohen inflation aus ihren taschen
geflossen ist wenn sie das jetzt
kritisieren dann müssen sie ihren
eigenen haushalt anders aufstellen oder
hätten ihren eigenen lasst uns paket
nicht zustimmen dürfen das ist nicht in
ordnung
zum entlastungspaket die angebotsseite
wir wissen dass alle bei der energie
fehlt vollkommen leider ist es
vollkommen ausgeblendet worden die
sozialversicherung geht weiterhin eine
unterfinanzierung wir alle wissen dass
sie auf sehr wackligen beinen steht dann
nimmt man jetzt noch mal geld raus und
die abschöpfung von zusatzgewinnen eine
tolle neue kreation für das wort
steuererhöhungen das müssen sie sich
eingestehen der ampel am ende wird das
die erste steuererhöhungen seien die sie
gemeinsam beschließen werden
und dieses ziellose stolpern zieht sich
wie ein roter faden durch die arbeit der
ampel regierung und das können wir uns
eigentlich in diesen zeiten in denen es
so schlecht ist nicht leisten und
deshalb haben wir als opposition und
werden wir als opposition vorschläge
machen um ihnen zu zeigen wie es besser
gehen würde wir verstehen uns
tatsächlich das wort kreation kommt hier
aus der fdp als service opposition wir
machen hier nicht aufwand auch wenn das
uns manche unterstellen wollen sondern
wir werden hier vernünftige vorschläge
machen und die situation die situation
im haushalt ist ja auch nicht vollkommen
neu aber vor der korona zeit hatten wir
noch haushaltsüberschüsse wir haben
keine schulden gemacht und natürlich war
es dann auch möglich dass eine oder bei
der einen oder anderen sache etwas
großzügiger sein das ist jetzt nicht
mehr der fall der haushalt ist auf kante
genäht und wir müssen an allen stellen
gucken was richtig ist und deshalb es
ist alleine schon richtig dass die
schuldenbremse überhaupt nicht in der
diskussion stellt ich frage mich wie
etwas was im grundgesetz steht und was
für jederzeit einhalten müssen andere
und wieder eine diskussion rankommt der
bundesfinanzminister hat mehrfach in der
vergangenheit darauf hingewiesen
der tanker aber eine einbringung des
haushalts hat auch noch mal allen
erklärt natürlich zusammen ökonomisch
sinnvoll jetzt die schuldenbremse 1 alle
neue schulden heißt anheizen der
inflation wir wollen doch noch dass
unsere enkel und unsere kinder noch
entscheidender entscheidungen treffen
dürfen und deshalb ist das falsch jetzt
die schuldenbremse anzugehen während
herr junker da sehr klar war herr
lindner muss sich jetzt einmal
nachfragen haben sie gesagt als ultima
ratio könnten sie doch noch mal über die
schuldenbremse nachdenken als ultima
ratio haben sie ausdrücklich gesagt und
dann denke ich mir ach ja das ist ja
keine politische entscheidung auch da
haben sie immer darauf hingewiesen was
sind denn die voraussetzung wir brauchen
eine außergewöhnliche
notsituationen die sich der kontrolle
des staates entziehen
außergewöhnliche notsituation sicherlich
ein begriff über dem mann reden darf
aber kontrolle des staates das was er
habe sich in dieser woche geleistet hat
bei der frage von wirtschaft und energie
das ist ein kontrollverlust ja das sehe
ich auch so das ist aber kein externer
schock das ist ein kontrollverlust
unserer regierung das ist schlimm genug
aber kein grund jetzt die schuldenbremse
aufzugeben nur weil der damit ein fehler
nach dem anderen
den letzten punkt den ich ansprechen
würde es das thema zinsen auch da dieses
jahr erstmals wieder 30 milliarden dass
das erbe von olaf scholz und zweierlei
hinsicht er hat zuviel
inflationsindexierte papiere ausgegeben
das ist das eine und anstatt auf
langfristige zinsen zu setzen
langfristige coupons auszugeben hat er
die alten hochverzinslichen aufgestockt
und hat dass die radio das agio immer
wieder vorbei jetzt haben wir ein
disagio haben 30 milliarden die wir
zusätzlich aufbringen müssen das ist das
erbe von olaf scholz die zinswende
verpennt und trotzdem freue ich mich auf
gute beratung und
für die spd fraktion hat das wort der
doktor thorsten rudolph
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin sehr
geehrter herr minister liebe kolleginnen
eine million euro schulden ist das viel
für die allermeisten menschen in diesem
land ist das natürlich viel sie könnten
direkt privatinsolvenz anmelden wenn man
dagegen der sehr gehobenen mittelschicht
angehört wie bekanntlich der
oppositionsführer dann tut eine
millionen euro schulden zwar weh man
kann das zur not finanzieren man muss
keine privatinsolvenz anmelden wenn man
bill gates ist dann schaut man kurz ob
nicht irgendwo noch ein milliönchen in
der schublade liegt die absolute zahl
sagt gar nichts kolleginnen und kollegen
es kommt darauf an welches vermögen und
welche einnahmen jemand hat was für
privatpersonen gilt gilt auch für den
staat die absolute zahl sagt gar nichts
genau deshalb ist die schuldenquote also
das verhältnis von schulden zum
einkommen genauer zum
bruttonationaleinkommen die
entscheidende zahl die schuldenquote
deutschland sie wissen dass es durch die
korona krise deutlich gestiegen direkt
aktuell 69 prozent das ist der
hintergrund vor dem die ampel im
vorliegenden haushaltsentwurf dem etat
aufwuchs wegen der korona krise
konsequent wieder zurückführt und 50
milliarden weniger ausgibt als noch 2022
und sogar 110 milliarden weniger als
dennoch kritisiert die union wir haben
gerade wieder gehört zum beim haushalt
22 und jetzt wieder eine angeblich
ausufernden schuldenpolitik und mahnt
einsparungen an aus der schuldenpolitik
hört sich an als würde die schuldenquote
weiter steigen in sehr verehrten damen
und herren das gegenteil ist der fall
erlauben sie mir den monatsbericht der
bundesbank aus dem juni mit dem titel
perspektive der deutschen wirtschaft für
die jahre 2022 bis 2024 zu zitieren über
den projektions zeitraum singt die
schuldenquote deutlich auf rund 63
prozent hinter dem rückgang steht vor
allem das relativ stark wachsende
nominale bibb im nenner trotz der
defizite sinkt die quote noch mal von
2022 bis 24 sinkt die schuldenquote
mitten in der krise um 6 prozent 6
prozent das sind rund 230 milliarden
euro
einhaltung der schuldenbremse bei hoher
inflation bedeutet eine riesige relative
entschuldung des staates und das in nur
drei jahren erzählen sie also bitte
nichts von expansive finanzpolitik
gerede von einer angeblich ausufernden
schuldenpolitik bezeugt allenfalls 1
eine eklatante ökonomische ignoranz
sehr verehrten damen und herren die cdu
fraktion fordert übrigens gleichzeitig
dass der staat die inflations gewinne
zurückgibt und einen vollständigen
inflationsausgleich vornimmt man weiß
nicht so genau was sie damit meinen
kollegen mittelberg hat jedenfalls an
dienstag noch kritisiert dass beim
entlastungspaket lediglich
steuermehreinnahmen zurückgegeben würden
wenn die cdu/csu sich selbst ernst
nehmen würde und ihre markigen
forderungen und tatsächlich einen
vollständigen inflationsausgleich wollte
bei dem der staat am ende weder besser
noch schlechter da stellt finanziell die
schuldenquote also unverändert bleibt
müsste sie sofort einen antrag auf
abschaffung der schuldenbremse stellen
und ein entlastungspaket von 230
milliarden vorschlagen aber ich gewöhne
mich immer mehr daran dass die cdu csu
im deutschen bundestag sich selber nicht
ernst nimmt
einerseits eine angeblich ausdruck
konnte verschuldung kritisieren und
zugleich einen vollständigen
inflationsausgleich fordern wie die
cdu/csu das tut dass es in diesen zeiten
einer hohen inflation der selbst
widerspruch ist politisches prinzip dazu
forderungen nach atomkraft und fracking
die irische entscheidung beim
mindestlohn die beibehaltung von 219 a
schrille debatten um gender gerechte
sprache wie sie ohne cdu für dieses land
einheit schweren die frühen 80er jahre
und dann vermisst der märz beim
bundeskanzler führung also der mann der
in seiner eigenen partei größte mühe hat
eine kosmetische micro frauenquote
durchzusetzen mit verlaub da muss ich
lachen
die damen und herren der bundeskanzler
führt dieses land mit ruhe und
besonnenheit durch die krise in diesen
schwierigen zeiten den sich viele sorgen
wegen des krieges und der dramatisch
gestiegenen preise machen ist unsere
botschaft an alle bürger innen dieses
landes you never walk alone es ist
deshalb richtig und notwendig die
bürger/innen um 65 milliarden euro zu
entlasten
es ist richtig gerade kleine und
mittlere einkommen zu entlasten
es ist richtig das bürgergeld
einzuführen
das wohngeld auszuweiten und das
kindergeld zu erhöhen und es ist richtig
die rentner innen und studierenden zu
entlasten
und ich persönlich muss sagen in
anbetracht der volkswirtschaftlichen
auswirkungen die wir zu erwarten haben
von einem energie preisschock und von
der allgemeinen inflation sie wissen wir
bekommen im oktober das herbstgutachten
und die steuerschätzung
kann ich auch sehr gut damit leben und
halte es für richtig dass wir die kalte
progression zurück führen an dieser
stelle kurz und knapp dieses dritte
entlastungspaket ist nicht nur richtig
wuchtig es ist auch zugleich sozial
ausgewogen und zielgenau unser land ist
zusammen stark diese koalition ist
zusammen stark der kanzler führt und das
ist gut so herzlichen dank
sagt torsten rudolph hierfür die
spd-fraktion es mitglied im
haushaltsausschuss und zu einer koch
jetzt gibt es noch eine kurze
intervention von der cdu/csu-fraktion
dankeschön präsidenten
eine kurze anmerkung sie müssen nicht
darauf antworten
der kanzler als auch sie und jetzt auch
andere kolleginnen der ampel kommen
immer mit dem never walk alone mit dem
you will never walk alone ich weiß nicht
ob sie es wissen warum dieses lied
überhaupt eine berühmtheit erreicht hat
es ist die hymne eines fußballklubs von
liverpool
der erste punkt dann ist ja gemacht umso
schlimmer ist es wie es verwendet wird
das lied hat bekanntheit bekommen weil
bei einem fußballspiel 70 liverpool
anhänger umgekommen sind und danach
dieses lied in ganz vielen stadion auf
der welt auch in den meisten in
deutschland gesungen wird in gedenken an
den tod dieser menschen und mich stört
es einfach dass man jetzt in der krise
den eindruck erweckte das wäre irgendwie
miteinander zu vergleichen ich will nur
darum bitten bei der wortwahl zukünftig
etwas pietätvolle mit dem menschen leben
die dahinterstehen umzugehen eine andere
bieter habe ich nicht das ist einmal
gesagt das darf man ja auch sagen so im
zusammenhang will nur für die zukunft
daran erinnern da etwas anders zu
agieren danke
[Applaus]
die möglichkeit zum antworten
ja haase
sozusagen ich finde es völlig legitim
dass sie das für sich so empfinden und
dann das das so sehen
wenn sie mal in einem fußballstadion
waren das lied gehört haben und
dass auch beispielsweise bei der
europameisterschaft gehört haben wissen
sie vielleicht welche bedeutung das wird
heute hat und ich glaube der ganz
zentrale punkt an der stelle ist dass
das was eben auch der finanzminister
gesagt hat und die botschaft an die
bürger in dieses landes ist keiner muss
in diesem winter hungern und frieren
keiner bleibt zurück und genau das was
damals passiert ist
dafür macht sich
die schau stahl das war in diesem das
darf in diesem winter nicht passieren
und die lage so wie sie ist ist
dramatisch und deshalb ist diese
koalition mit ihrem 65 milliarden euro
entlastungspaket höchst
verantwortungsvoll und gibt den
bürgerinnen und bürgern ein signal so
dass sie in diesem winter mit zuversicht
gehen können und nicht durch diese
preisschocks sich die sorgen machen
müssen dass ihr leben ihre wohnung ihr
essen nicht mehr finanzieren können ich
glaube in der hinsicht drückt diese
dieser claim unter dem das steht das aus
was wir tun und gibt auch genau die
zuversicht die wir brauchen danke
und gebühren der debatte fort und der
nächste redner auf die fraktion ist
wolfgang bieler
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin
kolleginnen und kollegen der
bundeskanzler hat ende februar die
zeitenwende ausgerufen und zwischen
ahnen viele was dass wir dieses land
bedeutet jenseits aller schönen reden
einen rasanten niedergang von
lebensqualität versorgung und
wirtschaftskraft
der haushaltsentwurf 20 23 steht im
zeichen dieses niedergangs die ware
neuverschuldung wird durch
buchungstricks verschleierte
und so schreibt der bundesrechnungshof
ihnen herr minister lindner und
natürlich der ganzen bundesregierung ins
stammbuch ich zitiere mit erlaubnis der
präsidentin der haushaltsentwurf wird
dem transparenzgebot nicht gerecht die
erheblichen ausgaben in sondervermögen
werden nicht deutlich und es fehlt der
ausweis der echten netto fix aufnahmen
in zahlen diese neuverschuldung beträgt
mindestens
78,2 milliarden euro und nicht 17,2 bis
ihr schreiben das ist mehr als das
vierfache die schuldenbremse ist damit
nur noch formal eingehalten dem geiste
nach aber rücksichtslos ausgeübt
wenn die ezb staatsschulden mit
gedrucktem geld kauft für das zur
geldentwertung
dafür waren wir von der afg seit es die
partei gibt
der haushaltsentwurf beweist die
entwertung des euro unfreiwillig auf
drastische weise
überall wo zahlungen in us-dollar zu
leisten sind wird mit einem wechselkurs
von 1 13 gerechnet aber wir alle wissen
dass der dollar längs der euro längst
unter die dollar parität gefallen ist
schattenhaushalte wie der über 100
milliarden euro schwere sogenannte klima
und transformations- fonds spielen bei
der verschleierung der haushalts
wirklichkeit eine besondere rolle der
ktf ist die spielwiese für die logi
projekte und umverteilung im moment
sammeln sich dort auf kosten der bürger
gelder aus den schwindelerregenden
strompreisen und wenn sie die neue
sorgen das neue sogenannte
entlastungspaket ohne nachtragshaushalt
für 22 am bundestag vorbei organisieren
wollen wird auf dieser schattenhaushalt
eine wichtige rolle spielt transparenz
allen geht anders
wegen des niedergangs deutschlands
zeigen vertreter der regierung gerne mit
dem finger auf andere
insbesondere in richtung moskau die
wahrheit ist aber dass der größte teil
der probleme hausgemacht ist
ehrliche politik im interesse
deutschlands müsste die ursachen des
niedergangs bekämpfen überall greift
ideologie um sich zb bei der
energiewende dass die sanktionspolitik
zuallererst deutschland schadet pfeifen
inzwischen die spatzen von den dächern
sie wollten doch mal gut regieren also
kümmerte sich darum
[Applaus]
mit entlastungspaket die symptome zu
bekämpfen bringt bestenfalls kurzfristig
erleichterung
die neuen haushaltslöcher müssen dann
künftige generationen stoffen diesen
aber wird das volkswirtschaftliche
einkommen aus vielen industriezweigen
fehlen die gerade ins ausland getrieben
werden oder in die insolvenz für alle
die mit diesem begriff etwas anzufangen
wissen
im gegensatz zur gesamtlage starten sie
herr minister ihr ministerium ihr
eigenes üppig aus beispielsweise steigt
der ansatz für dienstreisen fast auf das
dreifache und sogar mehr als das
siebenfache der ist zahlen von 20 1
wir von der fdp-fraktion freuen uns auf
die haushaltsberatungen in den kommenden
wochen und ich sage voraus einem solchen
unausgewogen intransparenten und in
wahrheit zu mehr als einem sechstel aus
neuen schulden finanzierten haushalt des
niedergangs wird die fdp fraktion nicht
zustimmen
volker thiele war das für die
fdp-fraktion
das ist in dieser woche ja auch der
erste durchgang des haushaltsgesetzes
also abgestimmte wird in dieser woche
zumindest nichts es stehen ja erst noch
die parlamentarischen beratungen an da
kann ja auch noch das eine oder andere
verändert werden sven christian kindler
jetzt für die grünen der
haushaltspolitische sprecher
[Musik]
lindner meine damen und herren heute ist
tag 197 seit dem schrecklichen angriff
russlands auf die ukraine das ist ein
fundamentaler angriff auf unsere frieden
und sicherheit ordnung europa wo wir wo
putin statt der stärke des rechts auf
das recht des stärkeren setzt imperiale
gewalt zu verschieben von grenzen
der einsetzen will zentral für unsere
politik in diesem schweren herbst und
diesem winter ist dass wir als koalition
in deutschland aber auch in europa
internationales gesellschaften und
staaten zusammenhalten und die spaltung
versuche die es gibt von wladimir putin
russischen regime durch energie kriege
durch cyber-angriffe die propaganda
durch hunger wo der korn kriegswaffe
eingesetzt wird das wird diese angriffe
weiter entschieden zurückweist unter
nach sonderrecht und kleine weiter
verteidigen
denn wir werden die menschen nur kleine
weiter unterstützen humanitär
diplomatisch mit waffenlieferung und
auch mit zusätzlichen notwendigen
sanktionen
und ich will nicht verhehlen dass die
lage extrem angespannt und schwierig in
diesem herbst und winter ist und das
stellt insgesamt auch unsere politik
auch die finanzpolitik vor große
herausforderung aber wir werden uns als
koalition diesen großen
herausforderungen stellen wir werden das
sich wegducken wir werden die
verantwortung annehmen wir nehmen sie an
und wir spielen nicht die notwendige
unterstützung der ukraine gegen die
notwendige unterstützung der bevölkerung
in deutschland aus wie es heute in der
debatte zum wirtschaftstag sacher
wagenknecht gemacht hat oder so wie es
gerade die afg als fünfte kolonne
moskaus des kremls gemacht hat das
werden wir nicht zulassen
[Applaus]
und deswegen hat auch der
koalitionsausschuss der finanzminister
des angesprochen ein großes
entlastungspaket am wochenende
beschlossen mit 65 milliarden euro mit
einer wirkung dass vor allem die kleine
mittlere einkommen in dieser schweren
krise sozial entlastet werden und der
wirtschaftsminister habe heute noch mal
ein wichtiges paket für kleine mittlere
unternehmen angekündigt zu dämpfen von
energiekosten das ist der richtige weg
und es offensichtlich der krieg
verschärft viele probleme die wir haben
die inflation trifft vereinigen uns auch
weil wir so abhängig sind von fossilem
gaza passieren öl und kollege haase von
der union hat auch die energiepolitik
der angesprochene wichtige fragen wer
hat uns dann sie abhängig macht von gas
und öl wert in den letzten 16 jahren
regiert jedes einzelne windkraftrad
blockiert warum waren die gasspeicher
leer als wir als regierung übernommen
haben und warum ist insbesondere bayern
und der csu in diesem winter so eine
grenze dass doch ihre verantwortung
und jetzt sind die gasspeicher bei 85
prozent werden vor der sommerpause das
größte paket für erneuerbare energien
seit 20 jahren beschlossen und der
finanzminister hat es angesprochen wir
haben ein team an transformationsphase
auf den weg gebracht mein volumen von
200 milliarden euro bis 20 26 und es ist
zentral bei wir nämlich damit
erneuerbare energien finanzieren wir
finanzieren energieeinsparung
energieeffizienz also machen sie
unabhängig von putins gras insgesamt von
gas und öl auch von anderen
autokratischen regime machen wir uns
unabhängig und gerade union klagt jetzt
erlegen das zeigt doch dass sie nicht in
der position verstanden haben auch immer
die energie blockieren werden wollen und
das werden wir nicht zulassen
man kann doch jetzt gerade in dieser
zeit nicht in klima transformations-
fonds kaputt machen wollen oder für
andere aufgaben auch nicht
zweckentfremden wollen wir sehen dass
die klimakrise massiv eskaliert durch
waldbrände durch überschwemmungen durch
die dürre durch die ganze hitze deswegen
ist für uns klar wir haben
koalitionsvertrag festgelegt dass wir
schauen wollen gemeinsames koalition wie
wir dieses instrument in diesem jahr
auch noch stärken können das werden wir
uns genau anschauen ist besondere
energieeffizienz müssen wir gucken was
da noch geht bei dass zentrales für
diesen winter
und liebe kolleginnen und kollegen wir
stehen international vor massiven
herausforderungen aufgrund einer der
schwersten hungerkrise seit jahrzehnten
weltweit fliegen extrem viele menschen
nicht nur kleine vor kriegen aber auch
vor der eskalierende klimakrise und
deswegen ist der bedarf an humanitärer
hilfe wieder krisenprävention auch an
den ernährungssicherheit so groß und uns
ist auch zentral dass wir in diesen
hauses beratung darüber sehr ernsthaft
diskutieren und zentralen stellen auch
nach steuern
und die klimakrise eskaliert wäre kroner
pandemien noch lange nicht vorbei ist
und ich blicke wenig wie der
finanzminister ökonomisch auf diesen
herbst mit auch sorgen denn wir haben
hohe fossil betriebene energiepreise die
eu und die bundeswehr arbeite daran auch
die runter zu kriegen indem wir ein
neues strommarkt design im hoch ein ganz
schöner zeit entwickeln werden indem wir
auch gucken dass wir puffer als gewinne
abschöpfen bei unternehmen und so auch
unternehmerinnen unternehmer und
verbrauchern verbraucher entlasten
werden und gleichzeitig haben wir neben
den fossilen ohne energiepreise nehmen
auch ein nachfrageschock bei vielen
verbrauchern verbrauchern weil sie
verunsichert sind unternehmen somit auch
gestiegene kosten nicht einfach
weitergeben können weil sich auch
massive probleme bekommen würden wir
haben eine situation wo banken jetzt
verschärfte kreditlinien verabschieden
werden für unternehmenskredite der
finanzhäuser das angesprochene ezb
erhöht jetzt den leitzins wegen der
hohen inflation das verschärft natürlich
an rezessionstendenzen das institut für
weltwirtschaft heute geht heute von
minus 0,7 prozent rezession im nächsten
jahr aus und deswegen sage ich auch klar
so ein drohendes ökonomische szenario
brauchen aktive haushalts und
finanzpolitik sie braucht einen
handlungsfähigen staat der die menschen
und unternehmen in diesen schweren
zeiten nicht im stich lassen unterstützt
will sagen sie wir werden sehen krise
nicht hinein sparen und das notwendige
tun das notwendige finanzielle budget zu
vier tagen
sagte sven christian kindler für die
grünen so nächste hier am rednerpult in
dieser aussprache zum einzelplan oder
acht ist der für finanzen ist christian
görke für die linke der sprecher für
finanzpolitik
frau präsidentin liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen sehr geehrter länder mit
haushaltswahrheit und haushaltsklarheit
hat ihr haushalt wirklich nichts zu tun
und ich sag's erstmal ganz platt sie
tricksen wo es nur geht und das müssen
sie auch weil sie das unmögliche möglich
machen wollen sie wollen die
schuldenbremse einhalten die wollen
keine über event steuer sie wollen keine
höheren steuern superreiche und
gleichzeitig investieren und menschen
entlassen und sehr geehrter herr kindler
das ist die quadratur des kreises und
das wissen auch spd und grüne nur zu
genau denn solange sie nicht wirklich
die superreichen unangetastet lassen bzw
unangetastet lassen und die
schuldenbremse nicht reformieren werden
die entlastung päckchen so sein wie sie
sind ernüchternd und auch teilweise eine
mogelpackung unternehmen wir mal wie das
letzte das letzte bisschen lauter
sowieso maßnahmen die ohnehin gekommen
wären
die sie einfach nur neu etikettiert
haben wie bürgergeld wohngeldreform home
office pauschale und den ausgleich der
kalten progression ich könnte das alles
noch fortsetzen und die zuschüsse meine
damen und herren die sie ausreichen
kommen nochmals gestiegenen einnahmen
der mehrwertsteuer circa 28 milliarden
und sie geben teilweise noch das zurück
was die menschen an steuern an der
zapfsäule bzw an der supermarktkasse
vorjahr bezahlt habe also linke tasche
rechte tasche und dann der
bundesfinanzminister sind ja am meister
im verkaufen und nehmen wir doch mal das
beispiel der kalten progression
abgesehen davon dass sie in den
absoluten zahlen und dass es nicht zu
widersprechen die gut und
spitzenverdiener in diesem land am
wissen profitieren lassen bei diesem
gesetzeswerk lasse sich die entlastung
dann auch noch überwiegend von den
kommunen und den ländern bezahlen von
den zehn milliarden euro
entlastungswirkungen das wissen sie die
zeit der bund gerade mal vier mal im
bild zu bleiben was sie auch übernehmen
sie stellen ein ganz großes menü
zusammen bezahlen die vorspeise und
schmeißen dann direkt rechnung dem
anderen auf den tisch und deshalb ist
auch die empörung in den ländern von
ministerpräsident bojko bis hin zur bodo
ramelow und doch zu den
cdu-ministerpräsidenten recht hoch und
die kann sie verstehen meine damen und
herren die haben ja angedeutet
und das war bemerkenswert die
schuldenbremse als ultima ratio erneut
auszusetzen aber wir steuern doch gerade
darauf zu die firmen hätten doch schon
nach und nach heute der autozulieferer
schneider götz hakler beispiele zu einem
betriebe und mitteln und unternehmen
aber was warten wir dann wir brauchen
zusätzliche spielräume und auch endlich
eine gaspreis deckel den wir durchsetzen
müssen denn die preisentwicklung beim
gas ist noch viel dramatischer als beim
strom und andere länder haben das vorher
macht also machen sie was und ändern sie
ihre produktive spannung diese den
ganzen sommer an den tag gelegt haben
und macht sie nicht schon wieder in den
nächsten stuhlkreis insofern hoffe ich
dass wir hier im gesetzeswerk der
haushaltsberatungen noch zahlreiche
änderungen vor dem vielen dank für ihre
aufmerksamkeit
und für die fdp fraktion erteile ich das
wort christoph meyer
frau präsidentin meine damen und herren
wir werden bis november diesen
regierungsentwurf beraten und in die
debatte heute hat auch gezeigt dass wir
trotz des massiven investitionsstau aus
der letzten jahre trotz der krise mit
denen wir uns beschäftigen können
trotzdem wieder zur einhaltung der
schuldenbremse kommen dass wir zurück
zum finanzpolitischen normalität kommen
und herr hase ihr bekenntnis zur
schuldenbremse heute ehrt sie und das
ist vielleicht auch eine rückkehr zur
normalität wenn man sich herrn söder und
herrn brown in den letzten jahr
vergegenwärtigt ist das nicht
selbstverständlich war ja union und
deswegen hoffe ich dass die sich hier in
ihren reihen durchsetzen können und
wir ermöglichen mit dem dritten
entlastungspaket in der tat zielgenaue
unterstützung und ich bin christian
linder sehr dankbar dass er das thema
abbau der kalten progression auch
richtig eingeordnet hat das eigentlich
darum geht im vorfeld von weiteren
entlastungsmaßnahmen als ein gebot der
gerechtigkeit den menschen nicht noch
mehr geld aus der tasche zu nehmen und
durch den abbau der kalten progression
hier so etwas die steuergerechtigkeit
herzustellen und ich finde es schade
herr hase dass sie den initiative den
vorschlag von christian linder eben zu
sagen dass wir in der tat hier zu einer
automatischen anpassung kommen sollten
was nach meiner erinnerung auch in ihrem
wahlprogramm steht nicht aufgegriffen
haben und sich hier vielleicht
eingereicht hätten in die argumentation
und wenn wir über die schuldenbremse
reden denn sollten wir so ehrlich sein
dass wir nicht nur über 20 23 reden
müssen sondern auch über 20 24 25 und
hier werden die waren bewährungsproben
für uns kommen weil die dann in der tat
sicherlich die rücklagen nicht mehr in
dem maße angreifen können und ich glaube
das ist das was wir hier zum thema
haushaltswahrheit auch sagen müssen dass
die nächsten jahre finanzpolitische
herausfordernd werden deswegen ist es
gut dass christian linder darauf immer
wieder wert legt das ist ein gebot der
verfassung ist das gilt für uns alle und
das ist auch in der tat zum dämpfen der
inflation die inflationserwartungen
wurden jetzt ja auch gerade von der ezb
noch mal nach oben angepasst eine
zentrale aufgabe dieser regierung sein
wird
wir müssen die staatsfinanzen
zukunftssicher machen und auch da wenn
wir uns das letzte jahr vergegenwärtigen
war der eine oder andere politische
akteur durchaus dabei
dreistellige milliardenbeträge über
kreditprogramme aufnehmen zu wollen ich
bin froh dass das sich jetzt so nicht
mehr materialisiert sondern zur jetzt in
der tat gering dass die schuldenbremse
eingehalten werde und auch das hat
christian linder formuliert dass am ende
wir uns darüber im klaren sein müssen
dass nur privatwirtschaftliche
investitionen hier den hebel für die
zukunft machen für die zukunftsfähigkeit
des landes und auch daran müssen wir
arbeiten und
die debatte die hier und auch am
dienstag bereits geführt wurde und die
auch mein vorredner schon wieder
versucht hat aufzubringen ist ja auch
interessant wir haben den letzten zehn
15 jahren so eine art raub und beute
gemeinschaft länder gesehen wir haben
jedes jede bundesratszustimmung die
irgendwo nötig war mit viel geld erkauft
als und und wir müssen einfach
feststellen dass die leistungsfähigkeit
des bundes an vier stellen hier
erschöpft ist und deswegen ist gerade
die union aber auch das gehört dazu sind
gerade die grünen ihren
regierungsbeteiligung in den ländern in
der verantwortung sorge zu tragen dass
die bundesländer sich hier ihrer
staatspolitischen verantwortung bewusst
werden wir haben die korona helfen zu
über 80 prozent durch den bund
finanziert wir haben im ersten halbjahr
eine deutliche schieflage bei den
finanzen zwischen bundes und länder und
kommunaler ausgaben und wir haben 50 55
milliarden euro ausgaben die der bund
für die länder übernimmt und die debatte
werden wir in den nächsten monaten
führen müssen wir reden ja eigentlich
über den einzelplan 08
und es ist natürlich ein tor und
deswegen glaube ich ist der aufschlag
den christian linder mit dem neuen
bundesfinanzminister
wochen gemacht habe ebenfalls hier zu
erwähnen auch wenn er sich in den
haushaltsberatungen 20 23 so noch nicht
materialisieren wird das zeigt dass wir
auch hier die versäumnisse der
vorgängerregierung angehen und ich hoffe
dass die bundesländer auch hier sich
ihrer verantwortung bewusst sind und
dazu einen beitrag leisten dass wir hier
auf einem guten weg kommen was die
bekämpfung von schwarzarbeit angeht
da kann man klatschen ja
ich könnte es noch ein paar sachen zu
union sagen zum beispiel
wer hat denn wert in die finanz die
inflationsindexierten anleihen
seinerzeit eingeführt das war doch der
bundesfinanzminister schäuble auf der
einen seite loben sie sich für die
schwarze null in den vorjahren auf der
anderen seite sagen sie einsatz danach
das quasi durch dieses instrument
letztlich letztlich hier hier
einen taschenspielertrick der
vorgängerregierung kann sie erzählen
jetzt dass die versuchen jetzt die das
abschmelzen der sinn rücklage im jahr
2022 bei den haushaltsberatungen dass
das in ordnung war am dienstag
kritisiert sie ist frontal und so
könnten wir alle einzelnen punkte
angreifen ich bin gespannt welche
maßnahmen sie im sinne des
rechnungshofes denn hier ein
konsolidierungsbeitrag in den
haushaltsberatungen einführen da können
wir dann diskutieren ich freue mich auf
die beratungen danke
und für die cdu csu fraktion hat das
wort yannick borel
präsidentin wir kolleginnen und kollegen
herr kollege meyer gestand sich mal eine
bemerkung zu beginn um das vielleicht
auch in der debatte noch einmal
klarzustellen die beseitigung der kalten
progression wird an der union ganz
sicher nicht scheitern weil es mich
vorher gegen überrascht hat war als ihre
finanz mindestens verkündet hat dass
außer der fdp fraktion von der
ampelkoalition nicht einer geklaut stadt
und lassen sie uns gerne in den
lackmustest machen im rahmen der
haushaltsberatung das thema teile
progression mit dem gemeinsamen maßgabe
beschluss unterlegen wir sind dazu
bereit liebe kolleginnen und kollegen es
ist es ist mehrfach hinter dem buch
angesprochen worden selten so sehr auf
eine kluge finanzpolitik angekommen in
der aktuellen situation die menschen die
familien in unserem land fragen sich wie
sie finanziell über den herbst über den
winter kommen soll die unternehmen der
volkswirtschaftliche kern von der
industrie bis in den mittelstand fragt
sich ob er denn den winter ökonomisch
überleben werde in dieser situation
kommt es auf eine gute finanzpolitik an
und herr minister ich bin ihnen dankbar
dass sie bis vorhin auch so deutlich
betont haben in der wir mit
fiskalpolitik mit fiskalischen impulsen
inflation nicht noch weiter anheizen ich
will aber auch dazu sagen dass wird die
bewährungsprobe oder eine der bewerbungs
probe für sie als minister nun werden
nachdem ihr start als finanzminister von
rekordschulden geprägt war da die kurve
jetzt hinzukriegen zu soliden haushalten
zu kommen und sich stahl wenn ich mir
die reden anschaue auch ihre ampel
partner sich da auch innerhalb ihrer
koalition durchzusetzen ich bin gespannt
auf die haushaltsberatungen in der
hinsicht und herr minister das gilt
nicht nur das gilt nicht nur national
das gilt auch auf europäischer ebene
denn neben der debatte um den
bundeshaushalt werden wir in den
kommenden wochen und monaten die reform
des europäischen stabilitäts und
wachstumspakt reform des europäischen
fiskal rahmen diskutieren und ja der
europäische stabilitäts und
wachstumspakt ist reformbedürftig aber
liebe kolleginnen kollegen nicht
deswegen weil die regel angeblich zu
streng wären sondern weil sie zu
kompliziert sind weil sie zu viele
ausnahmen zulassen und damit schlicht
nicht durchsetzbar sind und auch
deswegen minister bin ich froh und ist
es gut und wichtig es kam deutlich zu
spät aber es kam dass sie sich mit
vorschlägen in die debatte eingebracht
haben was aber da nicht zusammenpasst
ist dass sie auf der einen seite sich in
der deutschen diskussion dafür feiern
lassen dass sie die schuldenbremse
richtigerweise wieder einhalten wollen
aber gleichzeitig vorschlagen die
europäischen schuldenregeln weich zu
waschen die europäischen schuldenregeln
rauszuhören und das tun sie es
beinhaltet der vorschlag der man sich
den mal genau anschaut ihnen zwei
beispiele nennen das eine beispiel ist
dass sie den verbindlichen schuldenabbau
fahrt also die verpflichtung die
verschuldung wenn sie die regel grenzen
übersteigt zurückzuführen de facto außer
kraft setzen wollen notwendig wäre es
den abbaupfad realistisch zu gestalten
ihn zu reformieren das ist das schlüssel
und nicht die faktische
außerkraftsetzung sie steht aber die
steht aber ihren papier drin um der
zweite punkt der mich auch herausgreifen
will ist dass sie die ausnahmeklausel
noch weiter ausweiten wollen damit den
stabil packt noch kompliziert hat noch
weniger durchsetzbar machen wollen alter
momentan ohnehin schon ist ihre
vorschläge verbessern die europäischen
schuldenregeln machen sie noch weniger
durchsetzbar und dieser widerspruch per
minister weckt erneut zweifel daran wie
ernst sie es mit solider finanzpolitik
wieder mein oder anders formuliert ob am
ende der liebe koalitionsfrieden in der
ampelkoalition nicht vielleicht
wichtiger ist als die prinzipien die sie
finanzpolitisch gerne und richtigerweise
ins schaufenster stellen herr minister
es geht in den kommenden wochen und
monaten um mehr und um wichtigeres als
in ihrem koalitionsfrieden es geht darum
finanzpolitik national und europäisch so
aufzustellen dass wir die inflation
bremsen genau daran werden wir sie
messen vielen dank
kategorie war es für die cdu csu
fraktion so ein redner haben wir jetzt
noch hier zur finanzdebatte zur
allgemeinen finanzdebatte auch der
einzelplatz finanzen fehlt hier runter
das ist carlos kasper für die
sozialdemokraten
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin sehr
geehrte kolleginnen und kollegen
sprudelnde steuereinnahmen eine
florierende wirtschaft und wachstum sind
spätestens seit diesem jahr keine
selbstverständlichkeit mehr das zwingt
uns jedoch genauer auf die von uns
finanzierten projekte zu schauen und
gegebenenfalls den rotstift anzusetzen
gerade deswegen lohnt es ist aber auch
noch mal auf die einnahmenseite zu
schauen und gegebenenfalls die einnahmen
zu erhöhen um das zu schaffen gibt es
mehrere möglichkeiten man kann erstens
steuer erhöhen und zweitens auf die
schuldenbremse nicht mehr einhalten es
gibt aber auch eine dritte möglichkeit
nämlich dass wir noch stärker gegen
steuerbetrug und geldwäsche vor
und da haben wir großen nachholbedarf
das hat uns nicht nach der kürzlich
erschienene rtf bericht sondern auch die
umsetzung der sanktionen nochmals vor
augen geführt jedes jahr werden laut
schätzungen in deutschland über 100
milliarden euro gewaschen hinterzogen
und nicht ordnungsgemäß abgeführt und
davon ist jeder euro schmutziges geld
einer zu viel
dieses geld stammt aus kriminellen
quellen steuerbetrug schwarzarbeit
drogen und menschenhandel und häufig
auch und das kommt leider zu wenig vor
umweltkriminalität dass schwester unsere
demokratie denn das vertrauen in
prozesse schwindet es schadet den
sozialen frieden denn die sozialkassen
werden wäre und letztendlich für das
eben auch dazu dass wir unsere projekte
nicht mehr finanzieren können dagegen
müssen wir stärker vorgehen
dazu auch wir ab effektive
finanzermittlungen wir müssen wissen wo
das unvermögen herkommt wo es hin fließt
wär's kontrolliert und vor allem wer
davon profitiert ich bin deswegen froh
dass unser bundesfinanzminister nun
einen vorschlag gemacht hat wie der
kampf gegen schmutziges geld besser
organisiert werden kann das war ein
erster guter aufschlag aber wir müssen
aufpassen dass nicht nur vorschläge
gemacht werden und von internationalen
berichten abzulenken wir dürfen nicht
nur vorschläge machen um sie ins
schaufenster zu stellen vorschläge sind
nur dann gut wenn sie durchdacht sind
und vor allem auch mit verschiedenen
akteuren abgestimmt was aber auf jeden
fall klar ist wir brauchen eine
bundesweite einheit die nicht nur
gezielte finanzermittlungen bei
verdächtigen vermögen durchführt sondern
auch internationale sanktionen
durchsetzen und sie kann eben nur dann
vorarbeiten wenn die entsprechenden
voraussetzungen geschaffen worden und
passende instrumente vorliegen vor allem
brauchen wir das instrument eines
bischofs wird oder also die möglichkeit
verdächtiges vermögen schon dann
einzufrieren denn bereits gebildete
risikomerkmale vorliegen und nicht erst
wenn eine straftat vorliegt dafür
aber auch ein transparenz register
dringend besser gemacht werden die daten
müssen vollständig seien und ihre
richtigkeit muss immer wieder überprüft
werden nicht zuletzt kann durch fehlende
angaben im transparenz register
verschleiert werden wer die kontrolle
über bestimmte firmen und damit auch zb
immobilien hat nicht nur das viele für
ihre pflicht zur eintragung eines
wirtschaftlichen berechtigten nicht
erfüllt haben häufig finden wir auch
verschachtelte firmenkonstrukt vor deren
spuren in steueroasen verlieren aber
allein ein transfer register reicht
nicht aus um klarheit darüber zu
erhalten
neben immobilien gehören brauchen wir
ein zentrales abrufbares und digitales
kunden und da erwarte ist dass die
länder ihrer verantwortung ebenfalls
gerecht werden
ich bin gelernte rechtspfleger ich weiß
also wie grundbücher geführt werden als
2014 mein studium begann hatten wir
bereits die diskussion um ein bundesweit
digitales und vernetztes kunden acht
jahre später sind wir anscheinend immer
noch nicht hier weiter und ein
vollständig digital immobilien register
wird wohl erst in ein paar jahren
möglich sein und deswegen will ich den
ländern sagen macht es besser macht es
schneller und werde teurer verantwortung
bei der geldwäschebekämpfung bewusst
ihr habt nicht nur nachholebedarf beim
immobilien register sondern eben auch
bei der kontrolle nicht finanzsektor war
bereits dort die kontrollen mangelhaft
sind kommen jährlich 30 milliarden euro
gewaschenes geld in den kreislauf
aber aber als grund haben hier
verantwortung und dieser verantwortung
kommen wir mit diesem bundeshaushalts
plan nach im einzelplan 8 führen wir die
stärkung des zeus fort die in den
vergangenen jahren unter finanzminister
scholz begonnen hat denn die erwartungen
an den zoll sind immer weiter gewachsen
das betrifft vor allem die polizeilichen
arbeiten wie die bekämpfung von
schwarzarbeit den schmuck oder eben auch
der kampf gegen produktpiraterie
umso wichtiger ist es dass wir nochmals
im haushaltsplan einstellen aufwuchs
beim zoll vorsehen wir investieren aber
auch weiterhin die dienstsitze der
hauptzollämter wir kümmern uns um die
beschäftigten des zolls damit sich uns
die steuern einnehmen waren abfertigen
und die einnahmen der sozial karten
sichern denn nur so geleistet
gewährleisten wir dass dazu auch
weiterhin über die hälfte der
steuereinnahmen des bundes einnehmen
kann kann sich diesen schluss jeder
investierte euro in die zahl lohnt sich
denn er kommt um ein vielfaches zurück
vielen dank
carlos kristall hier aus setzte räder zu
diesem einzuplanen 08 der hat auch noch
mal zu sagen ein hinweis gegeben wofür
das geld eigentlich was hier formal
unter das finanzministerium fällt das
ist ein relativ kleiner etat von 5 1
milliarden euro viel von diesem geld
fließt in die ausgaben für die
zollverwaltung und beispielsweise ist in
diesem etat auch eine wiedergutmachung
summe des bundes von ungefähr 14 3
milliarden euro veranschlagt für die
entschädigung von opfern des
nationalsozialistischen verfolgung also
dass